first of all in a nutshell what is a
circular economy and how can it help us
tackle climate change
the best way to describe a circular
economy is to look at today's economy
which is linear so we take a material
out of the ground make something out of
it and then the products get thrown away
within a circular economy you take a
material out of the ground you make sure
that product stays within the economy
for as long as possible so it's all
about eliminating waste and pollution to
keep that value in the system
circulating the materials that sit
within the products that sit within the
system and most importantly regenerating
natural capital so actually making sure
the biological materials have the
ability to regenerate land
and it sounds like a pretty fundamental
change to how we're doing things now are
you talking about a whole
wholesale systemic change to our economy
and if so that's a very big ask isn't it
it's a big ass but it's a massive
opportunity and if we look at today's
economy we take a material we use it and
then we throw it away in the long term
that that simply can't run we have
finite resources available to us and
also we're releasing many greenhouse gas
emissions within a circular economy you
have a massive opportunity to reduce
emissions by keeping those products and
materials in use in fact 55 of carbon
emissions can be cut through switching
to renewable energy which is very
understood but a circular economy can
help to tackle the remaining 45 percent
so we're just a few weeks away now from
the cop26 u.n summit
all the talk around that is about
reducing our use of coal about financing
developing countries and also about
improving global emissions targets so
how does your circular economy fit into
that wider picture
well circular economy can help to tackle
the 45 percent of carbon emissions that
switching to renewable energy can't
touch that's how we make things how we
produce things including food if we
switch to regenerative practices within
those sectors we can massively cut
global emissions and this is about
incentivizing the right business model
shift it's about incentivizing farming
to be circular and regenerative so it's
not just a conversation about switching
from fossil fuels to renewable energy
which is obviously absolutely vital but
it's also the conversation around how we
decol decouple economic growth from
resource constraints
and and what are the priorities in those
other industries outside of energy then
it's about eliminating waste and
pollution when we design products so
designing things so there's no waste and
there's no pollution it's about making
products sit within a system for as long
as possible and that could be anything
from apparel to vehicles making sure
they're remanufacturable and then once
they come to the end of their design
life they can be
the materials can be recovered and put
back into the system and most
importantly it's about biological
materials
allowing them to regenerate allowing
them to go back to the land and helping
biodiversity to thrive which is
currently a massive challenge globally
so bringing this back to the cop talks
what does success at that meeting
look like to you
i think an agreement around what needs
to be financed is crucial obviously
finance is a huge part of switching from
a carbon heavy intensive economy to one
which uses far less carbon a lot of the
renewables incentives have been brought
into place in the developed world but
what about other incentives how about
incentives to how we make products and
use products how about incentives to
help farmers farm in a different way and
businesses to run in a different way
that's where the conversation needs to
go as well
and you've just been appointed an
environmental advisor to the scottish
government so what's your view on what
their priorities should be
from the circular economy perspective
obviously this is where my my my
interest and my my my hope lies there's
obviously a very clear switch to
renewable energy but within circular
economy it's about helping businesses
bringing in legislation to build that
circular economy so how can scotland
lead the way to build a circular economy
working with businesses working with
farmers working with actors within the
economy to switch from that linear
straight line to that circular economy
which is ultimately regenerative and
restorative and has a massive impact on
carbon emissions what about your view on
the cambo oil field off shetland
the uk government says this is up to the
oil and gas authority now to make a
decision about whether or not it should
go ahead what's your view on it
within a circular economy the idea is
that you can keep those materials in the
economy for as long as possible so oil
would turn into plastic plastic would be
recycled that would massively reduce the
need for that virgin oil obviously we're
not in a circular economy yet we do have
a need for oil to power much of our
economy but we have to look at how we
can switch from that linear consumption
of oil to that circular system
so day melon as a yachts woman you broke
the world record for the fastest solo
circumnavigation of the globe in 2005.
so how do you go from that to promoting
circular economies
well when you sail around the world on a
boat you have with you finite resources
so literally what you take with you when
you leave is all you have until you
finish and you develop this overwhelming
understanding of what finite really
means
and i suddenly translated that
definition of finite that i felt so
clearly on board the boat to our global
economy and realized that you know we
have finite resources available to us
once in the history of humanity and yet
our economy uses them up and in the long
term that really can't run so i then set
my my sights on trying to understand how
does the global economy run how do we
use resources yes we're using them up so
how can we use those resources
differently and that led to the circular
economy
and i can see that connection but but
how different does it feel i mean you
must have so much adrenaline when you're
racing as a yachts woman does this job
if you like feel very different
in some ways it's very different of
course you know i never thought i'd be
speaking to you about economics for
example when i was racing around the
world but actually when you race around
the world you set yourself a goal and
that goal is to break the record or to
get back alive or win the race but
actually within this new challenge the
circular economy this is about the
future of our global economy it's about
the future of humanity and actually it
really matters and it's really important
that we have a goal set to what that
could look like and that's what led me
to the circular economy
looking at how can we use resources in
our world that's a goal this isn't about
running away from a problem but it's
about running towards a solution and
since we set up the alamo carter
foundation in 2010 our goal has been to
look at the economics into a circular
economy to accelerate that tradition to
transition to a circular economy to
truly understand what that looks like
globally and we now have a network of
thousands of organizations and
governments across the world working on
that path